[Musik]
Die Geschichte ist eine internationale Geschichte, sie
hat politische Seiten, sie hat diplomatische
Seiten, aber letztendlich ist es eine persönliche
Geschichte auf der persönlichsten Ebene von
uns als
Eltern, man kann aus Deutschland kommen, ich kann
aus Israel kommen, man kann weiß sein, ich kann sein
schwarz, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es
zwischen dir und mir einen Unterschied in
Bezug auf unsere
[Musik]
-Kinder gibt. Das sind meine Töchter, wenn
sie auf das Bett springen. Ich habe Angst,
dass sie fallen und auf den Kopf gestoßen werden,
also stell dir vor, wie ich  fühlen, wenn
sie gefangen gehalten werden